what's up everybody I'm so excited
because today we are going to unbox this
entire Star Wars bitty Bop collection
from Funko just look at how cute and
tiny daddy Vader is what you get in this
box are 36 bitty Bops with 12 different
designs of our most beloved heroes and
villains who will we find let's find out
we've got Luke Skywalker Obi-Wan Kenobi
Jawa Princess Leia R2D2 C3PO Han Solo
Chewbacca Greedo Darth Vader TIE fighter
pilot and Stormtrooper there are all so
cute and precious that Chewie holds a
special place in my heart if you're a
Star Wars collector this is something
you might want to expand your collection
with it's a short win of three sets so
there's plenty to go around for your
friends and family
[Music]